.
Auf und davon -
jede Auswanderung ist einzigartig.
Nur in einem sind sie sich ähnlich:
Alle haben Hochs und Tiefs.
Doch noch selten hat das Schicksal
unsere Auswanderer so heraus-
gefordert wie in dieser Staffel.
Zwei Berner haben Grosses vor:
Alain Aegerter und Anita Thomi
wandern
auf den griechischen Peloponnes aus.
Mit dabei:
über 60 Schildkröten und Schlangen.
Ihre Idee:
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Aber das Schicksal
hat einen anderen Plan:
Ein verheerender Waldbrand legt ihr
neues Daheim in Schutt und Asche.
Doch weder Alain noch Anita
wollen aufgeben.
Eigenständigkeit
und Zeit miteinander,
das sucht Familie Rotzler.
In Schweden
soll der Wunsch Wirklichkeit werden.
Mitten im Wald
kaufen sie eine Ferienanlage.
Gratis dazu: viel Gerümpel.
Die Anlage auf Vordermann zu bringen,
wird zur Herkulesaufgabe.
Gerade halten.
Bleibt da noch Zeit
für mehr Familienleben?
Auf Prince Edward Island glauben
Barbara Hasenböhler und Thomas Range,
noch etwas bewegen zu können.
Ihr riesiges Anwesen wollen sie in
ein exklusives Guesthouse umbauen.
Der Plan
ist bis ins letzte Detail durchdacht.
Doch es kommt anders:
Barbara bricht sich einen Knöchel,
fällt aus und die Möbel kommen
erst einen Tag vor der Eröffnung an.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Verträumte Klänge *
Unterwegs in Schweden. Ein
langgehegter Traum soll wahr werden.
Familie Rotzler will hierherziehen.
Noch fehlt das Zuhause.
Was heisst Auto?
Kannst du
bei der nächsten Toilette anhalten?
Wir machen nicht nur Ferien.
Unser Hauptziel ist,
ein Haus für uns zu finden.
Wir hoffen,
dass wir etwas Tolles finden,
wo wir für immer oder
zumindest sehr lange bleiben werden.
Wir suchen
ein neues Zuhause für uns.
Ich will nicht in Schweden wohnen.
Schau, dort ist eine Schaukel.
Ja, also ...
- Dort vorn ist ein Parkplatz.
Hier machen wir einen Zwischenstopp.
Ja, Familie Rotzler ist auf der Suche
nach einem neuen Zuhause.
Alle sollen sich wohlfühlen.
Knapp zwei Wochen
sind sie auf Entdeckungstour.
Achtung, pass auf,
der Boden ist etwas schlammig.
Auf der Fahrt
geben die Kinder den Rhythmus vor.
Töchterchen Fiona muss mal.
Meine Güte, ist das ruhig hier.
Wow!
Keine Autos, keine Trams - nichts.
Raus aus der engen Schweiz
und mehr Zeit für die Familie.
Mit dem Auswanderungswunsch
der Eltern
nehmen auch die jungen Leben der
Kinder eine gänzlich andere Richtung.
* Lachen *
He.
Sie merkt schon,
dass Veränderungen anstehen
und dass es langsam ernst wird.
Sie findet das
natürlich nicht nur toll
und die Herausforderung für uns ist,
ihr gerecht zu werden.
Wir müssen ihr das Ganze erklären
und versuchen,
ihre etwaigen Ängste abzubauen.
Das ist eine Challenge
für uns als Eltern.
Wir müssen unseren Job gut machen.
Ich denke,
dann wird das funktionieren.
Die Reise soll
auch den Kindern Spass machen.
Nicht acht, sondern neun Gäste.
Wir versuchen, es für die Kinder
etwas spielerisch zu gestalten,
z.B. indem wir die Besichtigung
mit einer Schatzsuche verbinden,
damit sie auch etwas davon haben.
Eigentlich
macht es uns bzw. mir Freude ...
Ja, Kian.
... eine so grosse Aufgabe zu haben.
Nach dem Stopp
geht's schleunigst weiter,
denn Sabrina und Jonas haben
den nächsten Besichtigungstermin.
* Sanfte Musik *
Eigentlich hatten wir alles.
Wir lebten den Schweizer Traum:
Wir hatten einen guten Job,
eine Familie und ein Häuschen.
Aber irgendwie empfanden wir immer
eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit.
Wir begannen, uns zu fragen, woher
sie kommt. Denn wir hatten ja alles.
Dann merkten wir,
dass wir etwas mehr Platz
und etwas mehr Freiheit brauchen.
Wir hinterfragten
auch das Arbeitsmodell.
Man arbeitet als Angestellter und
setzt sich in der Firma Stress aus,
den man mit nach Hause bringt.
Man arbeitet nicht für sich selbst,
sondern für jemand anderen.
Man steckt seine ganze Energie
also nicht in etwas Eigenes.
Wir fragten uns, was wir
dagegen tun können und beschlossen,
unser Leben zu ändern.
(Navigationsgerät)
Ankunft, Ziel auf der linken Seite.
Ihr neuer Lebensentwurf:
Ein Grundstück erwerben,
auf dem sie auf irgendeine Art
Tourismus anbieten können.
Dort, wo die vielen Autos stehen,
ist meist die Besichtigung.
In Torsaker
befindet sich das Kaufobjekt -
ein Grundstück mit mehreren Gebäuden.
Das könnte ihre Zukunft sein.
(Barbara) Sufi,
zieh nicht wie ein Esel!
Barbara und Thomas' Auswanderung
begann mit einem Drama.
Eigentlich sollten sie
schon lange auf und davon sein.
Und trotzdem ist heute
ein Tag zum Feiern.
Wir sind heute
seit 18 Jahren zusammen.
Heute sind es 18 Jahre.
- 18?
Ja, 2003 ...
Richtig.
- ... bis 2021. 18 Jahre.
Vor 17 Jahren wanderte Thomas
wegen mir zum ersten Mal aus -
in die Schweiz.
Genau, im Mai 2004.
- Genau.
Das war weniger ...
- ... spektakulär.
... weniger dramatisch.
Das Drama: die Pandemie.
Die beiden waren
auf dem Sprung nach Kanada,
als das Land den travel ban ausrief,
also die Grenze dicht machte und die
Schweizer nicht mehr einreisen liess.
Dabei wartet in Kanada
eine riesige Villa auf sie.
Diese wollen
die top ausgebildeten Gastroprofis
in ein Guesthouse umbauen.
Kein Job,
keine Wohnung, nur Ärger und Frust.
Und das über 14 lange Monate.
Doch für Barbara galt schon immer:
Geht nicht, gibt's nicht.
Ich bin eine Person -
das ist nicht unbedingt gut -,
die einfach nicht aufgeben will.
Aufgeben ist für mich ein Wort,
das es eigentlich gar nicht gibt.
Und so begannen sie, den Umbau
von der Schweiz aus zu organisieren.
Nun endlich
ist die Grenze wieder offen.
Noch wenige Tage,
und die beiden sind weg.
Das ist schön.
Der Herbst ist eigentlich die
schönste Jahreszeit auf der Insel.
Diesen können wir nun
dort verbringen.
Wir müssen arbeiten ...
- Ja.
... und endlich loslegen,
aber wenigstens sind wir dort.
Wir müssen nicht mehr
alles von hier aus planen
und Tausende Stunden lang Video-
konferenzen oder Telefongespräche
mit Architekten,
Bauunternehmen usw. führen.
Wir können einfach hinfliegen
und uns mit den Leuten
an einen Tisch setzen.
Während des langen Wartens
hatten die Gestrandeten
bei Verwandten Unterschlupf gefunden.
Einige Wochen nächtigen sie
bei Barbaras Bruder am Zürichsee,
gleich neben einem Winzer.
Dieser ist nun
zu einem Freund geworden.
Jemand zu Hause?
- (Mann) Ja.
Nun heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Das ist sozusagen unser
zweites Zuhause bzw. eines davon.
Absolut.- Diesen Wein
packten wir in unseren Container.
Denn er ist ein Stück Heimat.
(Tröstend) Ja.
Die ... Hey.
Die Tränenintensität
hat in der letzten Woche
schon fast dramatisch zugenommen.
Du kannst mal den Wein mitnehmen
und ich hole die Gläser.- Super.
Aber ihr kommt uns besuchen,
nicht wahr?
Ja, wir kommen mal vorbei.
Aber lieber im Sommer.
- Danke für die Freundschaft.
(Frau) Here you are.
(Englisch)
So ...
Wir sind in einem fremden Haus,
Kinder.
D.h., wir schauen alles mit den
Augen anstatt mit den Händen an.
Das Kaufobjekt in Torsaker
ist direkt an einem See gelegen.
* Eines der Kinder plappert. *
Das ist der Wohnbereich.
- Der Schlafbereich.
Mama, Papa.
- Eine Schlafkoje, wie süss.
Eine total süsse Lösung.
Eine Schlafkoje,
in der jedes Kind ...
Nicht anfassen.
- Hier schläft nächste Nacht jemand.
Okay.- Es riecht einfach
überall heftig nach Katzen.
Boah! Bis ein solcher Katzengeruch
draussen ist ...
Ich finde es gar nicht so extrem,
aber wenn du das sagst.- Doch.
Ich bin sogar noch leicht erkältet.
Trotz Geruch - einziehen
könnte die Familie hier schon bald.
... mit dem Trottinett.
Mit dem Trottinett Runden zu drehen,
findest du lustig, was?
Sabrina führte in der Schweiz
einen Onlineshop,
und Jonas
arbeitete als Qualitätsmanager
bei einem Transportunternehmen.
Jetzt wollen sie
in den Tourismus einsteigen.
Ob Ferienwohnungen, Restaurant
oder Hotel - da sind sie ganz offen.
Jetzt kommt Papas Traum.
Doch zuerst kommen die Kleinen dran.
Nun platziere ich die Süssigkeiten.
Bonbons
für die Schnitzeljagd der Kinder.
Hier?
- Ja, hier.
Es gibt Platz für Autos.
Die Werkstatt
würde ich nicht übernehmen.
Schau dich
beim Rausgehen ganz genau um.
Oh!
* Jonas lacht. *
Was ist da drin? Schau mal rein.
Schwedische Bonbons.
Mmh.
Ein Gästehäuschen gibt es bereits.
Hier könnte man ein Bett
reinstellen, aber nicht viel mehr.
Hier fehlen die Gästehäuschen.
Was meinst du?
Wahrscheinlich ist es zu wenig Land,
um noch mehr Gästehäuschen zu bauen.
Ja, es beinhaltet einiges ...
... was gut ist.
Die Gästehäuschen
müssten woanders sein.
Und der Preis müsste tiefer sein,
damit wir genügend Kapital hätten,
um woanders Gästehäuser zu kaufen.
Zu viel Wenn und Aber:
Torsaker fällt durch.
Im Emmental soll bald eine
kleine Menagerie auf Reise gehen.
Jahrelang
war dieser idyllische Garten
das Zuhause der kleinen Schildkröte.
Doch bald wird sie
mit 40 Artgenossen auswandern.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Alain, ihren Besitzer,
zieht es nach Griechenland.
Zusammen mit den Stubentieren,
nämlich 24 Klapperschlangen,
und seiner
langjährigen Partnerin Anita.
Hallo, Schnuckelchen.
Bist du schon fast bereit?
- Ja.
Wieder mal.
Anita arbeitete jahrelang
als Personaldisponentin.
Also, ich verabschiede mich.
- Tschüss.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Dir auch.
Früh zur Arbeit, damit er noch
etwas vom Tag, von seinen Tieren hat,
das ist die Devise
des gelernten Elektromonteurs.
Bald schon
hat er seinen letzten Arbeitstag.
Ich mache das seit 15 Jahren.
Irgendwann hat man genug.
Es ist nicht so,
dass es mir nicht mehr gefällt,
aber es wiederholt sich,
es ist immer ein bisschen dasselbe
bzw. ähnlich.
Daher wird es mir
nicht grossartig fehlen.
Seine Passion ist die Herpetologie:
die Wissenschaft der Amphibien
und Reptilien.
Deshalb hatte er einst eine
Ausbildung als Tierpfleger absolviert
und gibt seit Jahren Kurse.
Salü, Ivan.
Doch zurück zu seinem Brotjob.
Tschau, Alain.
- Salü, Ivan.
Es ist schade, dass er geht.
Tja, nichts ist für die Ewigkeit.
* Ivan lacht. *
Bei einem langjährigen Kunden
steht eine letzte periodische
Überprüfung der Elektroanlagen an.
Im grossen Bauernhaus in Biglen
verteilt Anita das Frühstück.
Bis alle Tiere gefüttert,
die Gehege gereinigt sind,
vergehen schnell 2 Std.
Sie befinden sich
im Umzugsprovisorium.
Sie kriegen etwas Brennnesseln
und etwas Löwenzahn.
Anita hat ihren letzten Arbeitstag
bereits hinter sich.
Nun kümmert sie sich
v.a. um den Papierkram.
Auswandern mit so vielen Tieren
ist ein gewaltiger Hosenlupf,
doch bis jetzt
lief alles wie am Schnürchen.
Bald schon hofft sie,
die griechische Haltebewilligung
für die Schildkröten und Schlangen
zu bekommen.
So.
Das ist das Einzige, woran ...
... es noch scheitern könnte.
Falls wir die Papiere für die
Haltebewilligung in Griechenland
nicht erhalten,
müssten wir die Reise verschieben.
Sind die Papiere da,
packen sie die Tiere
in einen Lastwagen und auf geht's.
Auf dem Peloponnes erwartet sie
ein Grundstück samt Wohnhaus
und ein Gehege für die Tiere
steht schon.
Ich freue mich sehr,
wieder etwas aufzubauen.
Das ist für mich
die treibende Kraft.
Ich bin sehr gespannt auf das,
was mich erwartet,
und auf all die Überraschungen,
die es geben wird.
Zurück lasse ich ...
... meine drei Töchter.
Aber sie sind erwachsen
und können mich jederzeit besuchen.
Ich kann auch
jederzeit zurückkommen.
In einem Tag bin ich hier.
Das Bauernhaus haben sie verkauft.
Bald schon
ziehen die neuen Besitzer ein.
Während gut zwei Jahrzehnten
war das Haus
auch Auffangstation für ausgesetzte
und vernachlässigte Reptilien.
Denn geht es um Tiere, können
weder Anita noch Alain Nein sagen.
Es verging kaum ein Jahr,
ohne dass neue Tiere
hier ein Zuhause gefunden hätten.
So wie Olga und Mimu.
Deren Besitzer hatte irgendwann
schlichtweg zu wenig Platz für sie.
Es ist eine riesige Freude,
zu wissen,
dass sie an einen Ort kommen,
dessen Klima ...
... für sie ideal ist.
Ich würde an keinen Ort auswandern,
an dem das Klima
für sie schlechter wäre.
Ginge es nach ihnen, dürfte es
sogar noch etwas wärmer sein.
Schau mal, magst du Spargeln?
Riech mal.
Nein?
Ich mag es gemütlich.
Daher passen sie schon zu mir.
Ich schaue mir die Dinge zuerst an
und studiere sie, bevor ich handle.
Daher besteht schon
eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit.
Das kann ich nicht abstreiten.
Trotz des Hangs zum Gemütlichen:
Der Gedanke,
mal irgendwo anders zu leben,
hat Anita schon immer beflügelt.
Als die beiden vor vier Jahren
den Peloponnes entdeckten,
konnte sich auch Alain vorstellen,
auszuwandern.
Der Peloponnes
ist ein Hotspot für Herpetologen,
für Amphibien und Reptilien.
Für europäische Verhältnisse
gibt eine relativ hohe Anzahl
an verschiedenen Arten.
Es gibt extrem viele Leute,
die z.B. Landschildkröten haben
und diese auch mal
in der Natur sehen wollen.
Das würden wir
den Leuten ermöglichen.
Ihre Idee: Bungalows bauen
und Ferien für Tierfreunde anbieten.
Weisst du,
wo das Video vom Drohnenflug ist?
Ja, schliess mal das hier.
Ich habe folgende Vision:
Hier oben wird unser Bereich sein.
Hier werden
unsere Schildkröten leben
und hier werden wir Teiche bauen.
Die Gäste können auf der Terrasse
ihren Morgenkaffee trinken,
während im Garten
die Schildkröten herumspazieren.
Das ist unsere Vision.
* Träumerische Musik *
Um die Kinder nicht zu überfordern,
besichtigt Familie Rotzler
nur ein Objekt pro Tag.
Doch Mittelschweden ist weitläufig,
die Anfahrtswege sind lang.
Bis die Familie endlich
in Sundsvall im Hotel ankommt ...
Hoppala.
... ist es schon Nacht
und alle sind hundemüde.
Geht's, Liana?
Klappbetten für die Kinder.
Oben gibt es sogar Ränder.
Schön, das ist bis jetzt
das grösste Zimmer.
Hier sieht man gleich den Parkplatz.
Doch was gibt es
Schöneres für Kinder,
als im grossen Bett der Eltern
einzuschlafen ...
* Sanfte Klänge *
... und auch wieder aufzuwachen?
Es schneit immer noch ein wenig.
Die Sonne zeigt sich auch.
Das wird ein schöner Tag.
Gehen wir die Häuser durch?
- Ja.
Sabrina und Jonas
haben einen klaren Plan.
Wir haben eine Liste.
Jedem Objekt, das uns potenziell
interessiert, geben wir eine Nummer.
Dann gehen wir eine Checkliste
durch, mit der wir alle bewerten.
Die Checkliste enthält
unsere Wünsche und Anforderungen.
Insgesamt
beurteilten wir etwa 20 Objekte.
Einige davon fielen aufgrund
unserer Checkliste gleich raus.
Diese brauchen wir
gar nicht zu besichtigen,
da z.B. das Spital oder die Schule
viel zu weit weg sind
oder weil die Kanalisation und
der Brunnen erneuert werden müssten.
Auf den Bildern sieht man das nicht,
aber wenn das alles zusammenfällt,
ist es ein bisschen viel.
Einen vielversprechenden Eindruck
macht die Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden.
Das sieht total süss aus.
Dort haben wir eine unverbindliche
Besichtigung mit dem Eigentümer.
Er soll uns zeigen,
wie das Ganze aussieht,
und ich hoffe, dass wir einen Blick
in seine Bücher werfen können.
So schlecht wie die Google-Bewertung
ist, kann es ja nicht ...
In einem Forum
wird es als Geheimtipp bezeichnet.
Mit einer Google-Bewertung
von 3,2, also ... Ich weiss nicht.
Ich glaube,
es ist auch sympathieabhängig.
Wenn man dort ist und es will, muss
man dem Verkäufer sympathisch sein.
Er verkauft ja sein Lebenswerk.
Sie schlafen.
- Seid ihr bereit?
Wofür?
- Für Hausbesichtigungen.
Ihr wollt den ganzen Tag
im Bett liegen und fernsehen, was?
Auf geht's.
Das wahre Leben, die Zukunft ruft.
So. Komm, Gini.
Nein.
Während einiger Wochen hatten
sich die gestrandeten Auswanderer
bei Barbaras Eltern
in Bern einquartiert.
Unser Wohnzimmer leert sich.
* Lachen *
So.
Bist du fertig?
- Nur noch Thomas' Velo.
Dann haben wir's.
- Super.
Letzte Gepäckstücke wollen sie in
ihren Schiffscontainer verfrachten.
Das ist das Velo
meines lieben Mannes.
Das ist sein Heiligtum.
Es ist zumindest
sehr wichtig für mich.
Ich freue mich
schon wahnsinnig darauf,
wenn es wieder zusammengebaut ist
und funktioniert.
* Barbara lacht. *
Barbara ist die Jüngste
der drei Hasenböhler Kinder.
Sie ist froh, dass ihre Schwester im
gleichen Haus wie die Eltern wohnt.
Zum Abschied
hat sich ihr Vater etwas ausgedacht.
Ich hatte die Idee,
ihnen dieses Buch mitzugeben.
Das ist quasi ihr Gedächtnis,
damit sie sich daran erinnern,
wo sie herkommen.
Ein Band voller Erinnerungen.
Das ist einfach so.
Das ist auch Barbara.
Dies ist Barbara in der Schule.
Sie wandern nicht aus, weil
es ihnen hier nicht gefallen würde,
sondern, weil sie in Kanada
etwas erschaffen können,
was in der Schweiz
schlichtweg unmöglich wäre.
Diese Insel hat
ein bisschen von allem etwas:
Sie ist klein wie die Schweiz
und hat für kanadische Verhältnisse
eine relativ
hohe Bevölkerungsdichte,
aber sie hat auch ein Meer
und erinnert somit an die Ostsee,
wo Thomas herkommt.
Wesentlich war für uns zudem,
dass der Tourismus
dort extrem wichtig ist.
Gleichzeitig haben wir den Eindruck,
dass man im Tourismus
noch etwas erreichen kann.
Es hätte ja nicht unbedingt
gleich Kanada sein müssen, aber ...
Frankreich wäre auch gut gewesen.
- Ja.
Es ist bittersweet.
Es hat von beidem etwas.
Man muss so etwas dann machen,
wenn man es machen kann.
So ist es.
Am 14. feierte ich
meinen 45. Geburtstag und ...
Ja, ja.
Irgendwann ist man zu alt.
Das wollen wir auch nicht.
Wir wollen dort
ja noch etwas aufbauen.
Und, äh ...
Solange wir
noch einigermassen fit sind ...
Mein Mann wird 80
und ich bin auch schon 76.
Wir können reisen,
das sind wir uns gewohnt.
Einmal pro Jahr
werden wir sie bestimmt besuchen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Off we go.
- Auf und davon.
So weit, so gut.
Das Wetter stimmt schon mal.
Noch vier Tage
und die beiden sind weg.
Im Zollfreilager in Basel steht -
seit über einem Jahr schon -
ihr Container, auch der
war während 14 Monaten blockiert.
Let's see.
Vor unserem Haus
sah er so riesig aus.
Nun sieht er aus wie ein Spielzeug,
was?
Sieht er rostiger aus? Nein, oder?
Die Befürchtung: Ihre Kleider
und Möbel, der ganze Hausrat
könnten Schimmel angesetzt haben.
Der Moment der Wahrheit.
- Aber es sieht gut aus.
Und es riecht auch nicht feucht.
Dann schmeissen wir es mal rüber.
Perfekt.
Gut fünf Wochen wird ihr persönliches
Hab und Gut unterwegs sein.
* Melodie von "Uf u dervo" von Gölä *
* Rasseln der Schlange *
Rasseln ist eine Warnung.
Das bedeutet: "Stopp, halt!"
Man muss einfach
Respekt vor dem Tier haben.
Ein Hundebiss
ist auch nicht angenehm
und ein Katzenbiss
kann zu einer Blutvergiftung führen.
Aber natürlich weiss man,
dass man ein echtes Problem hat,
wenn man von einer
solchen Schlange gebissen wird.
Schau, hinten
ist noch ein Rest Haut.
Trotz Giftschlangen -
die Auswanderer sind einen
entscheidenden Schritt weiter:
Die griechische Behörde hat ihnen die
Haltebewilligung für 41 Schildkröten
und 24 Klapperschlangen erteilt.
Ohne Tiere auszureisen,
wäre für mich undenkbar.
Wenn wir die Bewilligung
nicht erhalten hätten,
wäre die Auswanderung
keine Option gewesen.
Nun benötigen sie noch
die klassischen Einfuhrpapiere.
Um diese zu erhalten, müssen sie
sämtliche Reptilien chippen.
So können sie
beim Zoll identifiziert werden.
Gut.
- Zack.
Du musst dieses Bein
so nach vorn halten.- Gut.
Danke.
Der Chip wird unterhalb des Panzers
beim Nacken injiziert.
Gut.
Alain und Anita
haben keine gemeinsamen Kinder.
Die Liebe zu Reptilien
hat sie seit Anbeginn verbunden.
Wegen Anita begann sich auch Alain
vermehrt für Schildkröten
zu interessieren.
Voilà.
Ursprünglich
hatte ich ausschliesslich Schlangen.
Vielleicht hat es
mit dem Alter zu tun,
dass man sich für langsamere Tiere
zu interessieren beginnt.
Das sind tolle Tiere.
Die Tiere sind gechippt.
Die Auswanderung
kann gefeiert werden,
denn der Abschied rückt immer näher.
(Alain) Das ist doch egal.
Hallo. Das ist meine Tochter.
Er sollte schon in Ordnung sein.
Er ist sicher lecker.
Meine Mama backte einen Speckzopf
und einen normalen Zopf.
Wunderschön.
Mum, du kommst nach Griechenland,
um Zöpfe zu backen, nicht wahr?
Ja, ja.
- Gut.
Sie haben schon lange darüber
nachgedacht und Pläne geschmiedet.
Ich glaubte
eigentlich nie wirklich daran,
aber nun ist es so weit
und ich freue mich extrem darüber.
Ich möchte euch alle
zu diesem Abschiedsfest begrüssen.
Es freut uns sehr,
dass ihr euch alle Zeit
dafür genommen habt.
Ich hoffe,
ihr bleibt noch ein Weilchen.
Das Büffet ist eröffnet.
Auch Anitas Tochter
unterstützt die Mutter.
Ich mache mir natürlich
auch Sorgen und befürchte,
dass sie krank werden,
dass irgendetwas nicht klappt
oder dass sie
existenzielle Probleme kriegen.
Das kann natürlich alles passieren,
aber ist das ein Grund,
es nicht zu tun,
wenn man spürt,
dass das sein tiefster Wunsch ist?
Gut. Geniess es einfach.
Hallo und tschüss.
Passt auf euch auf.
- Pass auch auf dich auf.
Kommst du uns mal besuchen?
- Auf jeden Fall.
(Tröstend) Oh!
Nochmals.
- Willst du nochmals?
Ja.
* Sie lachen und seufzen. *
Tschüss. Tschau, Mama.
Tschau-tschau.
* Sanfte Musik *
Familie Rotzler
ist wieder in der Schweiz.
Der Alltag ist zurück,
der Papa am Arbeiten.
Doch bald ist alles anders: Sabrina
und Jonas haben ein Objekt gefunden.
Hier.
Folgendes ist der aktuelle Stand:
Wir stecken
in den Vertragsverhandlungen.
In den nächsten
eineinhalb bis zwei Wochen
werden wir unterschreiben.
Wir prüfen die Verträge noch,
aber es sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Wir haben
unser neues Zuhause wohl gefunden.
Für das neue Zuhause
geben sie ihr altes her.
Das Haus
im solothurnischen Witterswil
steht kurz vor dem Verkauf.
* Bellen *
Hallo, kommt rein.
Und bald schon
sind spontane Familienbesuche selten.
Willst du auch spielen gehen?
Willst du Vanessa zeigen,
wohin es uns verschlägt?
Vanessa ist Sabinas Schwägerin.
Wo ist es?
Das ist die Einfahrt.
Das ist das Schild. Auf der
anderen Seite steht der Name.
Im oberen Stock
ist auch eine Wohnung.
Wenn ihr zu Besuch kommt,
könnt ihr dort wohnen.
Das ist das Restaurant.
Die Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden
hat trotz der schlechten
Google-Bewertung das Rennen gemacht.
Das ist eines der Häuschen,
die wir vermieten.
Mit Sonnenschein und Schnee
sieht es total idyllisch aus.
Wir kamen dort an
und fühlten uns gleich wohl.
Das war für uns
einfach der ausschlaggebende Punkt.
Wir müssen uns beide
am selben Ort wohlfühlen.
Wir kriegten Fiona
fast nicht mehr weg.
Sie wollte im Schnee bleiben
und genoss es total.
Es ist ein gutes Zeichen, wenn
die Kinder nicht mehr wegwollen.
Es ist
etwa 1 Std. nördlich von Falun.
Ich finde es schon
ein bisschen schade, dass sie gehen,
aber wir waren darauf vorbereitet.
Sie sprechen schon
seit Jahren von Schweden
und davon,
dass sie mal auswandern wollen.
Mein Bruder sagt immer:
"Es ist schade wegen der Kinder,
aber wegen der Schwester
ist es okay."
Das sagt mein Bruder immer.
Noch zum letzten Mal
gemeinsam ins Muki-Turnen -
zu Fuss, weil hier in der Schweiz
so vieles gleich um die Ecke ist.
Fiona, deine Haare sehen aus,
als ...
* Die Kinder rufen durcheinander. *
Thank you.
* Sie lacht. *
Monatelang haben sich Barbara und
Thomas nach diesem Moment gesehnt.
Nun dürfen sie endlich
auf Prince Edward Island einreisen.
Such a long time.
- Too long.
Die Hunde
sind im Handgepäck mitgereist.
Alle sind munter und wohlauf.
Carol, eine Bekannte,
fährt sie nach Hause.
Prince Edward Island ist fast so
gross wie Barbaras Heimatkanton Bern
und ist die kleinste Provinz
des Landes.
In St. Peter's Bay
erwartet sie ihr Haus.
Als wir dieses Haus kauften,
war es Winter.
Wir sahen unser Haus, so seltsam
das auch klingt, nie im Sommer.
Wir wissen zwar anhand von Fotos
und Videos, wie es aussieht,
aber es ist immer anders,
es live zu sehen
anstatt es auf Fotos zu sehen.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
So schön, so schön.
Eight is what you're looking for,
right?- Yeah.
Okay.
Ah!
Ja, Sufi.
# Ta-da.
So.
So, das ist unser Zuhause.
Bienvenue, welcome.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist der Hammer.
Ihr Zuhause,
eine 570 m2 grosse Villa.
Im amerikanischen Fachjargon
werden diese herrschaftlichen Villen
Mansions genannt.
Das erste kanadische Essen.
Sufi, sitz.
Sitz. Warte.
Gina, warte. Nein, Gina, warte.
Warte.
* Händeklatschen *
Gratulation.
Wie schön, Sufi.
Hier könnt ihr
nach Herzenslust herumrennen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Direkt am Atlantik: ein
riesiges Mansion im Hampton-Style.
Kaum ist es hell, sind
anderntags alle schon auf den Beinen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Thomas ist
an der Ostsee gross geworden.
Die Schweiz hat er liebgewonnen,
doch das Rauschen des Meeres
hat er immer vermisst.
Für mich
fühlt es sich an wie ein Sonntag.
Denn zu Hause, in der Schweiz,
briet ich immer nur am Samstag
oder am Sonntag Speck.
Daher ist es fast wie ein Sonntag.
Oder einfach ein Stückchen Heimat.
Denn noch ist alles fremd und neu
in diesem riesigen Haus.
Bon appétit.
- Danke fürs Kochen.
The first breakfast.
Das reicht.
Ich würde sagen,
dass wir uns mit all den Schaltern,
Türen und Treppenstufen
eher schwertaten.
Die Orientierung
ist noch nicht wirklich vorhanden.
* Bellen *
Gina!
Die Garage
wollen sie zu Gästezimmern umbauen.
Während Monaten
besprach Barbara virtuell
mit dem kanadischen Architekten
die Baupläne.
Es gibt zwei Stufen.
Nun können sie diese
endlich vor Ort nachvollziehen.
Wir machen den Boden
ja ein bisschen höher.
Und dann ...
... wird diese Pony Wall
durch eine Wand ersetzt,
die bis zur Decke reicht.
Denn dies sind die Träger. Diese
Träger müssen wir berücksichtigen.
Sie bleiben?
- Ja, genau.
Diese Träger geben eigentlich ...
... die Grösse der Räume vor.
Hier ist das eine Zimmer.
Hier ist alles offen
und man sieht die ganze Meeresfront.
Endlich anpacken - die Zeit
des langen Wartens ist Vergangenheit.
Auch im Emmental
schien alles perfekt zu laufen.
Schien -
doch nun klemmt es irgendwo gewaltig.
Die Einfuhrpapiere für die Reptilien
wollen und wollen nicht kommen.
Doch die Zeit drängt,
denn die neuen Besitzer des Hauses
bringen schon erste Möbel.
Wir leeren schon langsam unser Haus
und bringen einige Dinge hierher,
damit wir nicht alles
aufs Mal machen müssen.
So kann die Familie,
die unser Haus gekauft hat,
auch schon mit dem Umzug beginnen.
Sonst kommt alles aufs Mal
und es gibt ein Chaos.
Der grosse Auszug der Tiere
findet also nicht
auf dem trockenen Peloponnes,
sondern im Emmentaler Gras sein Ende.
Sie fühlen sich zart an, was?
- Mhm.
Schau mal. Voilà, super.
Noch dürfen die Gestrandeten bleiben.
Das ist wunderbar.
Wir hätten es
nicht besser treffen können,
dass wir noch hier wohnen dürfen.
Es hätte sein können,
dass wir mit unseren 80 Tieren
obdachlos werden.
Das ist positiv, aber so langsam
möchte ich schon aufbrechen.
Es ist total ungewiss,
wann die Bewilligung kommt
und wie lange wir
noch hier sein werden.
Gut. Nun machen wir hier ...
Schau, sie öffnet das Maul.
Halt ihn mit beiden Händen
unter dem Bauch gut fest.
Dann fällt er nicht runter,
falls er zappelt.
Super.
Den Kindern der neuen Besitzer
gefällt's.
Vielleicht nehmen wir euch
mit nach Griechenland.- Ja!
Ja?
* Sie lacht. *
Nun ist die Laune schlecht.
Nicht mehr Besitzer, sondern
Gast auf ihrem einstigen Bauernhof.
Anitas und Alains
vorläufiges Zuhause: ein Wohnmobil.
Der Container mit ihrem Hab und Gut
ist bereits
nach Griechenland unterwegs.
Eigentlich sind sie guten Mutes. Nur
um die Tiere machen sie sich Sorgen.
Im Juli schliesst sich irgendwann
das Fenster wegen der Hitze.
Wenn 30-35 °C herrschen, können wir
keine Tiere transportieren.
Dann würden sie sterben.
Das ist das nächste Problem,
das irgendwann entsteht.
Ob es ihnen gefällt,
bis im Herbst zu warten,
bis es wieder kühl ist ...
Nein, das muss jetzt schnell gehen.
Mahlzeit.
- Guten Appetit.
Doch dass
die Einfuhrpapiere nicht kamen,
wird sich bald
als grosses Glück erweisen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon" ...
Skal.
- Skal, welcome to Sweden.
(Englisch)
... sind die Rotzlers stolze Besitzer
einer riesigen Ferienanlage.
Bald wollen sie eröffnen.
Nun haben wir drei Wochen Zeit.
In diesen drei Wochen gibt es extrem
viel zu tun. Dann eröffnen wir.
In Griechenland reisen
die Berner vorerst ohne Reptilien an.
Unser eigenes Bett aufzustellen,
ist das Zeichen,
dass wir wirklich hierbleiben.
Noch ahnen sie nicht,
was auf sie zukommt.
Trotz grossem Arbeitselan -
der Umbau kommt nicht in die Gänge.
Dies ist eine Insel.
Das bedeutet auch, dass es nicht
unendlich viele Handwerker gibt.
In St. Peter's Bay nimmt Thomas
einen Nebenjob in einem Café an
und Barbara freut sich über
Kartoffeln von der Farm nebenan.
# ... uf der Suechi
für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023